[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu vou começar com 12 perguntas
a primeira é retórica isso viajássemos
mais
a segunda pergunta é um pouco mais o
clube à segunda pergunta um pouco mais
pouco viagem entre a favor não joga uma
vez chuvas chegaram pra eu explico
há cerca de dois anos estava viajar à
província na e estava a visitar uma
cidade pequena no centro do país chamada
goiás cidadão tem um pouco
era mais uma vila ea 45 minutos do
goiano
havia um tempo ao tempo mas só no tempo
histórico construído no quadro do século
após cristo ea maneira mais fácil de
chegar o templo era de moda
eu não sabia andar de mota
mas um amigo meu um amigo meu que o
placar aumentava a ver não isso não é
nada fácil
então devo malva cerca de 10 a 15
minutos no parque de estacionamento de
uma praia e eu pensei que eu quem já
fernando mota
e quando digo mota quer uma desculpa
para aquilo não era bem mota com culpa
plata fashions
temos assim e ocidental a visitar o
tempo mas só uma desculpa pata numa o
percurso teve que passar por uma
autoestrada ferramenta atualizado pelos
gamers mais recônditos do país naquela
naquelas ao invés do treino no centro do
vietnã a minha mota começa a fazer um
barulho muito estranho
eu não sendo um mecânico não sabia não
fazia ideia que a maioria daquela e
estava a passar mal de e vejo um senhor
mais velho vietnamita a fazer um sinal
comigo não com os braços assinar e eu
interpreto isso como orgânica diz é para
rapaz sair desta moto está fazendo
barulho perigoso na faixa magoar
eu não falo uma palavra do que tramita o
senhor não falava uma palavra de inglês
xvii mas enquanto entendemos com gesto é
o para mota sair da mota
ela é muito simpática convidou uma
sentar na sua garagem e oficina que era
aquilo
viver não há muitas voltas de cada
segunda casa uma oficina de motos
sentei com o senhor chamou o filho um
público tenha porém os dez anos que o
filho estava aprendendo inglês na escola
então foi buscar um livro de anotação e
serviu como nojenta
eu achei a perguntar se já fala como
toda confia em mim e na minha filha
dizia pra mim inglês ou espanhol e
inglês o que eu dizia pra ver pra mim tá
a dada altura é o nome que o senhor está
muito interessado na minha aparência
começa a tocar a minha barba
tudo bem começa a tocar boca belo e de
repente seu braço o rosto dessa passada
o momento a corte não acordei naquela
manhã a pensar que hoje seria o dia
iriam tirar o próximo número do vietnã
mas pensa isso caminhar
eu era o primeiro ou um dos únicos não o
único negro companhia senhor havia
cruzado
que eu saiba a região centro o governo
não não antes no turístico let's dos
africanos foi simpático já a minha mota
foi mais um a 15 quinze minutos traz
mais agradáveis uma aguinha sozinho e
ficou pelo caminho até o tempo mas só no
segundo tempo num sítio fantástico
comparava o croata cambodia
e eu quando vou a lugares assim tempos
museu xuxa eu gosto é as placas todas eu
sou um pouco o pique é para como tempo
não equipe dia e pra mim efeitos assim é
como se vai saber o que pedi ao ver ao
vivo
avelar ler uma placa em uma sonda
chinesa está comigo por favor
cria uma foto não foto do tempo ou dos
artefactos de centenas de anos estavam
lá uma foto comigo
uma simpática sofre com a senhora vai
continuar outras placas e até ter as
fotos do tempo ruim do magnífico e vem
outra senhora chinesa está comigo queria
tirar uma foto e não do tempo não dos
fatos centenas de anos acabou a história
do maior desconto máximo da cultura
hindu no vietnã não tenha uma sofre
comigo
cinco anos depois vem o grupo que
ensinar jorge
o projovem urbano foi contigo então eu
num tempo continue no quarto do século
após cristo uma a maior atração
turística na rua na zona do goiano no
meio de ensino nessas atiramos uma foto
minha
então peço pra muita gente
imagens como esta não está muito longe
imagens de turistas africanos pelo mundo
não são muito comuns
isso porque existe um olhar ao
ocidentalizado sobre o turismo mundial
o turismo também no continente e isso
não é nunca daqui atribui culpa sal
assim vendendo algo assim mas muitas
vezes nosso próprio história da morte só
se preferirem os nossos próprios
ministérios de turismo fazem o marketing
de áfrica virado apenas o motorista é
europeu ou americano não
há muito intresse digamos assim em fazer
campanhas de marketing para o turista
africano
quantas vezes você já se viram num
carthage de morte em turismo da itália
por exemplo uma família africana a
passar pelo coliseu de roma
quantas vezes já viu um cartaz de uma
rua em qualquer das bahamas onde está em
primeiro para nossa família africana
é como se não existisse turistas negro
eo africano sabemos que não é bem assim
por outro lado nós quando viajamos vou
dizer analisar muitas vezes vamos mais
consentimento ou com um objetivo
consumista em vez de experienciar as
cidades lugares
vamos lá portugal tem que passar muito
tempo no shopping com você mas vamos com
o brasil idem e talvez fosse mais
interessantes nós começamos a ir para os
lugares em que vivemos os lugares
especiais da cidade tanto fora do
continente como também dentro do
continente que os continentes em cidade
incríveis e quando falamos do turismo em
áfrica sendo que o estereótipo do safari
vamos lá ver onde conheceu o o simba eu
faça tirar uma foto com uma zebra uma
girafa qualquer quando na verdade
existem em uma cidade por nosso
continente com uma rica cultura do
paraná onde faz músicas cria artes com
muito bem e é muitas vezes ignorada da
narrativa sobre turismo no continente
isso tem uma razão muito simples porque
nós não tenhamos os nossos conteúdos
para consumo mundial porque quando assim
acontece
quando assim acontece nós temos mais
contou da narrativa e podemos contribuir
para as imagens e os conceitos que
passam pelo mundo afora acerca do nosso
continente
aqui uma página que você deve conhecer
vai falar não vou me alongar muito o que
fazer mas já sabem em que a gente
explora este conceito de criar conteúdo
local feito por locais para consumo
mundial
mas essa não é a única nem a maior
língua já mais importante não é só eu
tenho algumas imagens de lugares em
áfrica onde saímos um pouco daquela
safari - uma ontem 2 aos fãs da banda
foto então não consegui assistir à
mostra um parque natural na vizinha
zâmbia tem um destino turístico pois
influência mas que não é assim tão
visitado por mais cinco anos apesar de
termos um vôo direto para usar cada
mostrando uma imagem de luanda duas
câmeras de vídeo a bola mostra um outro
uma outra visão da cidade em si um canto
superior inferior direito tem uma imagem
poderia ser tirada de qualquer resort
nas bahamas mas aqui ao lado e
madagáscar ou seja madagáscar não é
apenas um filme da disney é mais um país
que vale a pena visitar
ele tem um ali tem um restaurante na
ilha principal do arquipélago de são
tomé é lindo mas pouco conhecido
ao menos estão a criação de conteúdos
advogar em uma plataforma mundial são
alguns sinais da mudança começamos a
velha na forma como nós falamos sobre os
nossos próprios países sobre os nossos
próprios nossa capacidade sobre nossos
próprios destinos
mas há mais existem plataformas no
instagram
eu vou focar um pouco mais não está
ganha
usamos a grama e é uma das novas
plataformas que nós temos para mostrar
em imagens existem várias plataformas
tem uma coisa à áfrica visitar free
favor nó fazem exatamente isso mostra um
viajante negros ou africanos em locais e
mundiais mostra turistas africanos à
volta do mundo mostra que a áfrica não
apenas um sítio para se fazer turismo é
também um sítio de onde saem turistas
que vão para diversos lugares do mundo
tão raro
não raro é tão raro é vermos imagens 3d
africanos pelo mundo
depois disso acontece no dia anterior
agora os artigos ganha agora os
principais jornais do mundo disse olha
acho que nem chegaram à final existem
breaking news
isso é positivo
finalmente estamos a conseguir mudar um
pouco da maneira que somos tratados num
nível internacional
estamos a trazer mais atenção por
continuem se para além do estereótipo
safáris e do sim vai do mundo faça
estamos a conseguir se inserir no
turismo mundial mas podemos melhorar
ainda mais
cada um de vocês tem a sua razão para
viajar pode ser por para visitar museus
por motivos históricos pode ser por
motivos étnicos
eu gosto de viajar para a comédia
eu acredito no turismo no gasto o
turismo
obviamente eu gosto de ir para museus
gosto de pagar valores da arte mas
quando viaja uma boa parte do dinheiro é
posta de parte
valeu bastante em restaurantes sejam
eles silva milan ou barracas de rua
então a grande maioria das minhas férias
no verão foi isso é o sentado numa mesa
rodeado de vários pacotes de comida
nós podemos fazer isso também aqui no
continente africano porque não viajar e
conhecendo continuando pelos seus pratos
essa é uma das milhares de razões que
nós temos para a conseqüência é um pouco
melhor os países que nos rodeiam
não precisamos sempre dá para um vôo
setor horas o 14 horas para termos
crianças fantásticas
não precisamos sempre detalhes dos
shoppings nos museus viajasse calorias
dadas hoje com hoje plantamos muitas
delas aqui mesmo nos países à volta de
angola ou aqui no continente africano
no meu caso eu costumo viajar e conhecer
culturas novas através da comida porque
eu acho que essa é uma das principais
maneiras de conhecer um povo novo
é o estômago então por exemplo se trata
aqui de uma sobremesa do benin
imagine ficar curioso como a gastronomia
do benin como é a junção da castanha
beninense pode colocar a minha processo
o antigo colonizador que eu possa
aprender sobre esse povo sobre esse país
toda a sua história sobre os sonhos da
sua gente
como sobremesa é interessante na
plataforma do trabalho eu fundei a foto
com mais likes no encerramento a foto
contato mais bonito um grande pacto com
juros de sábado e não é nada disso
com mais likes na minha plataforma
em seguida por centenas de pessoas
muitas pessoas dentro e fora do país é
calulo carne seca com feijão de o palma
e funk do combo no butiquim da amac ou a
loop nash
então se nós compartilhássemos mais a
nossa prioridade aqui no país e não só
partilhássemos mais com o resto do mundo
nós próprios com os nossos telemóveis
que nós com nossos essas contas do
instagram a forma como nós vivemos as
músicas nós dançamos a arte nós criamos
estaria assim se anda o impacto na
maneira que as pessoas lá fora e mesmo
aqui dentro
vem um país de pagar seus mais e se vê
já somos mais
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]